et pour en parler nous sommes nous en
direct avec laurent leylekian analyste
politique spécialiste de l'asie mineure
et du caucase du sud également françois
à costantini géopolitologue bonsoir
messieurs et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france tout d'abord laurent
leylekian comment avez vous accueilli
cette reconnaissance par dubaï donne du
génocide arménien écoutez je crois qu'il
faut l'accueillir avec gratitude c'est
quand même quasiment une première le
président reagan avait déjà parlé du
mieux que je me suis d'armes ayant 180
et de manière anecdotique
là c'est au moment du 24 avril c'est
donc au moment du jour de la
commémoration du génocide arménien et
c'est par une déclaration qui est
absolument remarquable dans ces termes
puisqu'elle ni de manière très claire de
noir ce qu'on appelle le devoir de
mémoire avec les valeurs démocratiques
et la nécessité une vigilance vigilance
afin que ce genre d'événement ne se
reproduise plus et aujourd'hui je crois
pour la plupart des arméniens mais
peut-être pas aussi pour beaucoup
d'observateurs la crainte est là c'est
que cette cure qui n'a pas changé cette
année à abidjan qui n'a pas changé non
plus puisque ce sont deux peuples frères
qui prennent en l'état en taille et
l'arménie et bien remettre le couvert et
se relance à nouveau dans une politique
génocidaire
comme ils en ont vraiment c'est
l'intention et vous françois costantini
est ce que vous salue également cette
reconnaissance de la part de joe biden
le génocide arménien c'est une
reconnaissance fait raison dans le monde
entier des plannings salle mais je suis
pas d'une dérobade
il s'agit d'un vote du congrès et il
faut savoir que c'est donald trump
notamment qui avaient bloqué en effet
qu'il a et qui avait mis son veto
notamment à laroque est l'essence du
génocide arménien en tant que deux mois
pour un certain nombre de choses donc je
pense qu'ils même si en effet le peuple
arménien ses descendants les harmonies
de se réjouir latine une il faut savoir
que certaines nuances à
c'est que ça participe également un
certain langage diplomatique aujourd'hui
contre les états unis la turquie est
beaucoup plus complexe que ça à mon sens
justement c'est une reconnaissance qui a
été fustigé un par recep tayyip erdogan
il dénonce la politisation par des tiers
son ministre des affaires étrangères
affirme lui que la turquie n'a de leçon
à recevoir de personne sur son histoire
est ce que c'était le but de joe biden
mettre un coup de pression sur air de
one françois costantini
vous savez des états unis n'est pas une
politique des plus angéliques
c'est un message clair que par by the
administration bayh dole veut faire
entendre tayyip erdogan est la
diplomatie turque que le temps de la
diplomatie de tron que j'appelle de
gendre à fils puisse concède qu'on ait
fait que jared kushner l'inspirateur
notamment aux parties la diplomatie de
donald trump notamment du plan abraham
est bon et du plan quelque peu
contestable israël ou palestinien qui
n'a pas n'a pas vu le jour
entretenait des relations très haut
niveau très étroite avec le propre fils
le genre de réaction tayyip erdogan et
que les rapports se faisait un peu de
personne à personne
là on vient de le département d'état
l'administration by donne est en fait de
signifier à la turquie peut désormais on
va rentrer dans des règles diplomatiques
beaucoup plus traditionnel avec
peut-être des bras de fer mais également
des accords
aujourd'hui il ya ce que j'appelle un
véritable marché aux enfers entre marché
pradon aux enchères un peu un lapsus
révélateur un ton moins cher entre la
turquie qui se trouve entre ses
relations avec la russie la russie mais
qui aujourd'hui bat quelque peu de l'ale
et sa présence travail traditionnel dans
l'otan donc on veut faire comprendre à
la turquie en effet qu'il faut qu'elle
choisit son camp qu'elle se place
notamment dans la ville des intérêts
américains
chose qui ne va pas de soi aujourd'hui
pour en effet le le gouvernement turc
donc que le la reconnaissance du
génocide arménien est en quelque sorte
un premier ne un premier message qui est
envoyé à la diplomatie turque en disant
qu'on va revenir à une conception
traditionnelle des relations
diplomatiques que les arrangements en
effet les petits arrangements que trump
et son gendre on avait avec which takes
the gun et son et son premier cercle
sont terminés donc qu'il faudra en
passer en effet par une révision des
relations diplomatiques au national
l'élection est ce que c'est une manière
pour dubaï devait de montrer une rupture
avec la diplomatie tel que l'a présentée
donald trump rabat très clairement rue
du jeu parfaitement d'accord je pense
que dans l'attitude de dubaï donne il ya
deux facteurs
il ya d'abord une approche qu'on
pourrait qualifier le néo wilson
wilsonienne si vous voulez le jeu donc
donc nous devrons wilson qui était
président américain démocrate des des
années 20 qui a énoncé des principes
justement très philanthropiques
avec 1 2 avec des volontés
d'intervention et d'émanciper les pubs
de les libérer
donc si on retrouve ça sans doute dans
la motivation de joe biden mais tout
aussi des accents de realpolitik
nous sommes à un moment où la turquie
prend ses aises avec le temps se fait du
pied à la russie elle a acheté des s-400
des missiles stratégiques russes qui
menace les f-35 et dans les chasseurs
américains
elle continue d'entretenir des liens
plus que trouble avec les djihadistes en
syrie et un discours finalement assez
aussi agressif vis-à-vis de l'occident
d'une manière générale mais aussi et
c'est peut-être nouveaux
vis-à-vis d'israël erdogan a revendiqué
il ya pas si longtemps que ça il ya deux
mois
jerusalem donc mais aussi possible que
les organisations une certain qu'ils
organisations juives des états unis ont
lâché le bing qu'elle effectue est
traditionnellement pour la turquie
et vous avez un ensemble de facteurs qui
font que aujourd'hui les ats-unis disait
un organe c'est la ligne la ligne rouge
est en train d'être dépassé 7 après deux
messages très clairement c'est la
realpolitik
quelles vont être les conséquences
pendant que joe biden a reconnu ce
génocide
est-ce que
des risques c'est l'otan qui bloquaient
le fait que la turquie et les états unis
sont tous les deux membres de l'otan est
ce que c'est ça qui bloquait jusqu'à
présent dans la décision de joe biden
pendant président américain a rendu
moins de reconnaître le génocide
arménien merci non ce n'est pas pour un
oui l'otan bien sûr où la turquie
apparaît de plus en plus comme un
problème mais jusqu'à présent nous
avions également un poids important
département d'état américain
au delà de l'otan promet une vision
globale des intérêts stratégiques des
états unis et jusqu'à présent me semble
que la turquie était vu comme un allié
qui promouvait les intérêts stratégiques
américains
aujourd'hui la turquie et peut être
perçu comme puissance envoie une
puissance régionale qui n'est plus comme
le disait mais je constate et donc qu'il
n'est plus en ligne avec les intérêts
stratégiques américains et salées des
américains qui a une vision globale
ç'a très bien été créé ce genre de
danger et mettre le holà donc en termes
de conséquences
je ne sais pas trop on peut on peut
imaginer un refroidissement encore plus
un événement encore plus fort de la
nature qui du bloc occidental
la turquie est très forte pour jouer de
la tension historiquement entre
l'occident et la russie elle a peut-être
voir avec l'iran
je vais peut-être reprendre ce jeu là ou
au contraire comme les turcs sont aussi
des gens intelligents avec une
diplomatie est extrêmement intelligent
revenir plus proche des états unis vous
françois costantini quelles vont être
les conséquences comment va réagir la
turquie sur le plan diplomatique
géopolitique
alors personnellement je le vois pas le
découplage dur à un découpage réel entre
la turquie les états unis pour plusieurs
raisons c'est que les etats unis eux
cible aujourd'hui la russie
l'administration baydan cible la russie
et je pense qu'elle va observer la
turquie en fonction de ses relations
avec la russie
et on sait aujourd'hui que c'est mon
sens j'ai toujours pensé que le
rapprochement entre la russie et la
turquie était un rapprochement de
circonstances mais qu'ils consentent
hurel qui ne pouvait pas être ce tunnel
la preuve c'est que sur plusieurs
théâtres aujourd'hui pour la libye
la série sur le haut karabakh les
positions se sont totalement divergentes
il faudrait en quelque sorte que russie
et turquie
ce accord pour par exemple faire cesser
le conflit en syrie avec l'iran avec
l'arabie saoudite les états unis pour
qu'ils tablent eux mans en quelque sorte
un état durable de bonnes relations que
je pense que les états unis en effet
entre la russie la turquie ils
choisiront la turquie c'est certain 9
n'a vu d'ailleurs de façon assez
étonnante
erdogan récemment apporté son soutien à
l'ukraine dans la crise ce qui est un
signe un conte ancien importance
stratégique cas pendant une
neutralisation d'ukraine pour pour la
russie on sait que là en effet s'il y
avait désormais un antagonisme en
théorie c'est turquie il est bien
évident que la turquie reviendrait dans
les intérêts stratégiques américains
je pense que avec les difficultés que
c'est bien évidemment parce que riz la
turque il faut savoir aujourd'hui la
turquie est une comédie est une
puissance régionale
elle a son propre quant à soi et elle a
une espèce de politique protéiforme dans
laquelle elle voit ses intérêts et je
pense que je ne vois pas les états unis
dans leur politique aujourd'hui se
découper la turquie notamment pour une
raison également qu'il ne faut pas
oublier c'est que l'administration
d'haydn qui est pour moi l'aube et
l'administration obama
trois également est une administration
qui a des liens particuliers notamment
avec la turquie et les pays d'obédience
frères musulmans auxquels la turquie se
rapproche et on sait très bien que
l'objectif d'obama au printemps lors des
printemps arabes de 2011 cd donner les
clés du prochain à rexel tygart dogan
est d'installer entre guillemets des
régimes dits islamistes démocratique au
pouvoir et je pense qu'il ya anguilles
et récurrent dans cette administration
byden qu'il faudra observer de très près
si beaucoup messieurs pour vos
éclairages merci françois acot santini
je rappelle que vous êtes géopolitologue
et merci à vous monsieur les clients
analyste politique spécialiste de là
mineurs et du caucase du sud merci à
vous